yeah
I guess most of Nova Corps want to
uphold the laws but these ones here
they're corrupt and cruel but hey that's
not my problem I ain't gonna be here
long I've escaped 22 prisons this one's
no different you're lucky the broad show
it up because otherwise me a group would
be collecting that Bounty right now and
you'd be getting drawn in quarter by
yondo and those ravages I've had a lot
of folks try to kill me over the years I
ain't about to be brought down by a tree
in a talking raccoon old what's a
raccoon what's a raccoon it's what you
are stupid ain't no thing like me except
me so this orb has a real shiny blue
suitcase Arc of the Covenant Maltese
Falcon sort of vibe
I have no words for an honorless Thief
pretty high and mighty coming from the
lack of a genocidal Maniac yeah I know
who you are anyone who's anyone knows
who you are yeah we know who you are who
is she
you said that
I wasn't retrieving the orb for Ronin I
was betraying him I had an agreement to
sell it to a third party
I am well that's just as fascinating as
the first 89 times you told me that what
is wrong with Giving Tree here well you
don't know talking good like me and you
so his vocabulistics is limited to i and
m and group
exclusively in that order I'll tell you
what that's going to wear real thin real
fast if I
hey
put that away
put those headphones off that's mine
those belong impound that tape and that
player is mine
hooked on the feeling Blue Swede 1973
that song belongs to me
[Music]
rich as sweet as candy
it's taste is
[Music]
when we're all alone
please